in the previous video we were talking
about transformers this architecture
that uses attention to give
unprecedented ly good performance on
sort of language modeling tasks and some
other tasks as well but when were
looking at language modeling and that
was in preparation to make a video about
GPG 2 which is this very giant language
model that has been there was recently
well it was recently not released
actually by open AI the way that they
generated the data set for this is
pretty cool to get enough text they went
to Reddit and they pulled every website
that is linked to from reddit do we have
any idea of how many days lots
literally everything was everything that
had more than three karma I think or
maybe more than two karma something like
that like anything that had somebody had
thought to post around it and at least
two or three people who had thought was
good enough to upload they scraped the
text from that it's pretty much just a
transformer it's not the the
architecture is not especially novel
they haven't done any like amazing new
new discovery but what they realized was
transformers it seems like the more data
you give them the better they do and the
bigger you make them the better they do
and everything that we built up until
this point is clearly not like we
haven't hit the limits of what this can
do we they thought we think we're
probably bottle necked
on data and maybe network size so what
happens if we'd like to turn that 211
what happens if we just give this all
the data and make a really big one it
makes sense to talk about the acronym
right so it's a generative pre-training
transformer so generative same as
generative adversarial network it
generates outputs to generate samples
your pre-trained is this thing I was
talking about all of the different
things you can use a language model for
right you can do you can do translation
you can try and resolve ambiguities you
can do summarization you can answer
questions you can use the probabilities
for augmenting other systems so yeah
there's a bunch of different benchmarks
for these different tasks that you might
want your language model to do and this
is what we talked about in the grid
worlds video of having these like
standardized problems with standardized
metrics and standardized data sets so
that if you're comparing two different
methods you know that you're actually
comparing apples to apples and this is
like very important it gives you numbers
on these things it's often quite
difficult expected to like you're
generating samples of text and it's like
how plausible is this text how realistic
does it look like how do you put a
number on that it's kind of difficult so
there's all of these standardized
metrics and the thing that people came
to realize which actually I mean I say
that as though it's like some amazing
discovery it's fairly obvious if you
train your system in a like an
unsupervised way on a large corpus of
just general English text and then you
take that and train that with the data
from this benchmark or the data from
that benchmark
you can like fine-tune it so you start
with something which has like a decent
understanding of how English works more
or less and then you say now I'm going
to give you these samples for like
question answering or I'm going to build
a system using that to solve to go for
this benchmark so it's pre trained you
start with something that's like a
general-purpose language model and then
you from that a fine-tuned it to
whichever actual benchmark or problem
you're trying to solve and this can give
you better performance than to starting
from nothing and training to each of the
benchmarks from scratch make sense and
so the point of the GPT 2 paper the
thing that makes it cool is they said
okay if we make a really huge one what
if we don't fine tune it at all what if
we just make a giant model and then just
try and run it on the benchmarks without
messing with it without showing it any
of their specialized data for that
benchmark just the raw general-purpose
language model how does that perform and
it turns out surprisingly well so this
is a very very large data set for text
it's about 40 gigabytes which actually
doesn't sound like very much but like
for text text that's insane right it's
somebody said that this was the size of
Google's entire index of the Internet in
98 so like it's yeah it's a lot of text
and they trained it on that and they
ended up with a 1.5 billion parameter
model but which is like a previous state
of the art system was 345 million this
is 1.5 billion so they've just made the
thing much much bigger and it performs
really well some of their samples that
they published quite captured the public
imagination you could say and now that
we've talked a little about the problems
that neural networks or any language
model really has with a long term
dependency
we can now realise just how impressive
these samples are because when you look
at them as a you know if you look at
them uninitiated you're like yeah that's
pretty realistic it seems to like make
sense and it's cool but when you look at
it knowing how language models work it's
like very impressive the the coherence
and the consistency and the long-range
dependencies so we can look at this one
that got everybody's attention the
unicorns one right so they prompted it
with in a shocking finding scientists
discovered a herd of unicorns living in
a remote previously unexplored valley in
the Andes Mountains
even more surprising to the researchers
was the fact that the unicorns spoke
perfect English and from there you then
say you go to your language model gbgt
and you say given that we started with
this what's the next word and what's the
word after that and so on so it goes on
the scientist named the population after
their distinctive horn of its unicorn
these four horned silver white unicorns
were previously unknown to science we do
have a clue here as a human being
unicorns for horned doesn't quite make
sense but nonetheless we're going okay
now after almost two centuries the
mystery of what sparked this odd
phenomenon is finally solved dr. Budetti
Jorge Jorge Perez Jo are G an
evolutionary biologist from the
University of La Paz this is impressive
because we've mentioned the Andes
Mountains in our prompt and so now it's
saying okay this is clearly you know
in a shocking finding this is a science
press release news article it's seen
enough of those because it has every
single one that was ever linked to from
reddit right so it knows how these go it
knows okay third paragraph this is when
we talk about the scientist we interview
the scientist right okay
first word of the scientist paragraph
dr. obviously right because this is the
now we're in the name of the scientist
what name are we going to give it needs
to be a name conditioning on the fact
that we have the Andes Mountains so we
need to get where we're in South America
the name probably should be Spanish or
maybe Portuguese so we get we get dr.
Perez here
and then evolutionary biologist makes
sense because we're talking about
animals from the University of La Paz
again this is the first sentence like
when you have that first clause that
introduces the scientist you always say
where they're from
so we say from the University of and
then university names tend to be the
name of a city what's the city where we
have the Andes Mountains so we're going
to Bolivia lapaz perfect and the thing
that's cool about this is it's
remembered all of these things that were
quite a long time ago several sentences
ago well it hasn't remembered them it's
paid attention to them across that
distance which is impressive but also
this is encoding a bunch of understand
understanding a bunch of information
about the real world right all that was
given all it knows is statistical
relationships between words but the way
that it comes out to us is that it knows
where the Andes Mountains are what kind
of names people in that area have what
their cities are what the universities
are all of those facts about the real
world because in order to have a really
good language model it turns out you
have to kind of implicitly encode
information about the world because we
use language to talk about the world and
knowing what's likely to come next
requires actual real world understanding
and that's something that we see in some
of the other things that they got it to
do you can see the real world
understanding coming through let's keep
going
University of a person several
companions were exploring the Andes
Mountains when they found a small valley
with no other animals or humans peres
see we're hanging on to him yep we're
referring to him again but now we've
changed it to be just the surname
because that's the format that people
use in news articles Peres noticed that
the valley had what appeared to be a
natural fountain surrounded by two peaks
of rock and silver snow presently others
then ventured further into the valley a
round about here in our article we
should have a quote from the scientist
right quote by the time we reached the
top of one peak the water looked blue
with some crystals on top and we're
talking about this fountain I guess it's
natural fountain we're referring back to
the previous int it's like everything is
relying on in contingent on earlier
parts of the text while examining there
by snipped paragraph while examining
these bizarre creatures the scientists
discovered that the creatures also spoke
some fairly regular English know when I
read that I
like okay this is now unusually good
because that's the second sentence of
the lead right where six paragraphs in
and it knows about this point I've
covered the first sentence of this
initial paragraph now it's time to talk
about this second sentence of the lead
even more surprising to the research of
us of the fact that they spoke English
and it completely ignored the speaking
English part until it got to the part of
the news article where that comes in
you've gone six whole paragraphs the
idea of accurately remembering that the
unicorn speak perfect English is like
that's very impressive to me and then it
goes into its gets a little bit unhinged
starts talking about it's likely that
the only way of knowing for sure if
unicorns are indeed the descendants of a
lost alien race is through DNA that's
read it really well it's not actually
stuff on reddit it's stuff linked to
from reddit but yeah this is this is
news articles men they seem to be able
to communicate in English quite well
which I believe is a sign of evolution
or at least a change in social
organization said the scientist that's
his evolutionary biology there right
right right yeah we know here's an
evolutionary biologist so so the the
coherence of this text is really
dependent on its ability to condition
what it's generating on things that it's
generated a long time ago so yeah so it
can generate really nice news articles
and it can generate all kinds of text
things that it anything that is
sufficiently well represented in the
original data set so that's GPG - it's a
really unusually powerful and like
versatile language model that can do all
of these different natural language
processing tasks without actually being
trained specifically on those tasks it's
really and that's that's why it's
impressive it's not that it's a it's a
brand new architecture or a brand new
approach or whatever it's just when you
make these things really huge and give
them tremendously large amounts of data
the results are really impressive in the
original data set so it will it will
write you the Lord of the Rings fan
fiction it will write you cake recipes
if we're like there's all kinds of
examples of different samples here's a
recipe for
some kind of peppermint chocolate cake
and it's got a bunch of different